well another day another war of words in
the Johnny Depp verse Amber Heard
defamation trial welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight You know the exes
have yet to take the stand but it is
clear that both sides have their uh
witness list stack and today it was
Amber's former assistant testifying for
Johnny Depp oh boy
see
see
Amber sat Stone Face coldly staring his
Exorcist in Kate James listed off
illegal drugs she alleges the actress
took it was all documented in a February
deposition tape played today in court at
times Kate gets testy and dismissive
that's all I remember I don't look for
details do you recall anything
all you didn't love Amber you didn't
like her did you any close relationship
has Ebbs and flows
Amber's attorneys tried to paint Kate as
a scorned ex-employee blindsided when
the actress abruptly fired her after
three years it was abusive in your
opinion blind rage multiple times
screaming at me abusive text messages
between 2 and 4 a.m The Barrage would
start
Johnny appeared transfixed as Kate
defended him did you ever see Mr death
break something intentionally never
break anything never throw anything
always completely passive they engaged
in what I saw as Mutual abuse
another deposition played today Dr
Laurel Anderson Johnny and Amber sought
couples counseling from her starting in
2015. Mr Depp says to her no one likes
you you're getting Fame from me
yesterday jurors saw some of the more
than 80 surveillance video clips from
Johnny and Amber's condo during their
alleged violent blow up in 2016. Depp
wasn't arrested but cops were called
their former friend and neighbor also
read text between him and Johnny do you
recall Mr debb ever telling you that he
hoped that Amber heard's rotting corpse
is decomposing in the trunk of a Honda
Civic yeah it was said attorneys are set
to call celeb Witnesses including Paul
Bettany Ellen Barkin James Franco and
Elon Musk Johnny accused both Franco and
the billionaire Mogul of having affairs
with Amber they denied them
Depp lost his original UK defamation
case involving Amber and the exes have
already reportedly each spent some 20
million in legal fees
the trial is expected to last a month
[Music]